okay I had my wow I had my I had my
teeth me because I couldn't sing with
them so here we go okay okay okay is
this invisaline what's happening I
literally it is like a little but I was
like I can't sing a song like this
you're fully committed right now I'm
committed I don't know if I'll have to
take them out for this interview because
I'm eating the teeth right now but it's
fine um talk like this too make me feel
good about myself um do you love
Halloween do you just you get into it I
love Halloween me too I have a real
connection with Halloween oh yeah you
know my co-star when I was a little girl
when I was 5 years old um Michael Landon
his birthday was Halloween and I always
loved him so much and then I did some
horror films you know that a few yes and
then um also um my daughter my eldest
daughter Farah is Born on Halloween I
did know that that's cool yeah so we
love to like decorate you know as soon
as Halloween October hits my whole house
is decorated inside and out because to
me it's like the kickoff of all the
holidays yeah and it's like Thanksgiving
Christmas that is true it's the kickoff
yeah oh I love the decorations thank you
that's my dining table at home right now
okay so I do want to come back to you
Farah who was born on Halloween you you
went so you're like having Halloween
like carving pumpkins and you go into
labor yes I was 19 years old I was
carving a pumpkin and I was pregnant and
went into labor and she was born at 8:13
on Halloween I mean it's kind of
incredible cuz your family's probably
all together anyway oh my family like we
have all my sisters Kathy Kim and I
we've all you know when we've given
birth we've all been in the hospital
rooms with each other oh wow and um her
husband Rick like videotaped all our
births I know that sounds really weird
but he did and yeah so when I looked up
I had my sisters for moral support you I
was a young mom I was terrified yeah um
and I had friends there my mom was at
the Polo Lounge in Beverly Hills and
brought like half the Polo Lounge with
her and I looked up and at one point
there was 19 people in the room when I
gave birth that's a little little it's a
little it's a little much I mean for you
I just mean that would be overwhelming
my sister Kathy took the baby first and
then she looked at my then husband and
said would you like to hold the baby so
so generous you know oh my God no so
here's the thing about did you do this
like I was so terrified I don't know why
but I was so terrified especi with my
first kid that somebody was going to
take my baby so I looked at my sister
like grabbed her and my ex and I was
like if you lose sight of my daughter I
will never love you again I had that
thaning need you to follow wherever she
goes and like I was like so nervous
about because you hear those stories I
also had that fear yeah it's a little
irrational but I don't care um so wait
so do you believe in like Supernatural
stuff Have You Ever Seen ghosts or stuff
like I haven't and I want to oh come
over to my
house um yes I they show themselves to
me they thank God they haven't actually
shown themselves cuz I don't know if I
wouldn't be here right now I would want
to see it you think that you think that
I 100% think it would be cool okay well
I have I've had some happen I've lost
both my parents and I've had some things
happen like a lot of things happen
especially after my mom passed away um
were very strange uh things happen like
lights going on where they weren't even
plugged in really weird things yeah so
um I have no doubt I believe in that and
then my house that I live in now was
built in like 1882 and moved by like
trolley in
1912 and I hear footsteps a lot everyone
in my family has heard the footsteps
yeah and Smokey Robinson actually used
to own my home and I was at an Oscar
party this past Oscars and he said oh
have you heard the footsteps yet I did
not need to hear that I was like I
wanted to believe that I was imagining
it but the funny thing is I it feels
safe though it's like a good spirit yeah
I don't feel insafe around it yeah but
we've seen the movies we don't know
what's G to happen those are movies
though I really want to see one Kyle
okay looks like not a fun dinner party
it seemed like it didn't go well so I I
don't have a lot of luck with dinner
parties apparent
so yeah we had a dinner party season one
called we refer to it as a dinner party
from hell yeah this is supposedly on par
if not worse than that oh no so um yeah
that was actually a crazy night
everybody lost their Marbles and we had
like current Housewives and past
Housewives we had Camille grar there
Denise Richards F Resnik was there we
had the entire cast and it just had the
makings of just a complete disaster you
know the producers were like yeah
yeah I mean I of course you know there
was tears there was screaming and you
know of course they're like are you okay
oh be fine right like yeah they do love
I I have to say that I've gone through
public separation and divorce that is
the worst thing ever we were talking
about in commercial break like how how
do you like I feel like I was on TV the
whole time too but in a different way
like yall shoot reality so they got
everything kind of behind the scenes
that they did and it was like you know
it's really hard because you know um you
know what we're going through we are
separated and it's amicable um um but
it's still really difficult and I wasn't
quite ready to share in in the beginning
and it was just painful no matter what
you know this is not what my fairy tale
was supposed to be girl so it's it is
really hard and everybody's weighing in
and people all of a sudden like you
crushed our dreams you know we don't
believe in true love like no we really
like what do you think I think about
true love right now exactly what do you
think I'm I got to worry about my family
I've got to worry about you know a few
million people too what they think and
it makes it a lot more difficult yeah I
do I do think though like being able to
be that vulnerable in that situation is
probably going to help a lot of people
just just feel like related you know
relate to it and feel not alone in it CU
that's the worst that grief and loss
even if it's something you want it's
something that went terribly wrong that
you did not see coming you know hard
wants to put like their spin on what
they think it is and you know um when
they really usually don't know at all
and they know so much about your life
and they think that we deserve to know
everything that's going on like what
caused this what happened and then if
you don't tell them they come up with
their own idea so it's just you know
which is super fun it's so much fun it's
so much fun I love reading lies about
myself every day it is so fun yeah and
my mom calls me my my mom I'm like
people lie like I'm like you know you're
I'm like Mom it's a lie it's not like
real like what's in and she's like I
don't know well people are going to
believe this and I'm like Just Let It Go
Elsa it's so hard I know um but you I
have to ask this too so y'all you you
went to a psychic yall did a psychic
reading and they people are saying that
they predicted the separation well yes
season one uh she said that your husband
does not emotionally fulfill you she
said to me um but funny thing is that
now everyone's like oh she was right she
predicted this but she also said oh it's
your second marriage oh then you're fine
you won't get divorc I I really do feel
like she was picking up on Camille
grammar because she was hiding their
issues and uh Kelsey did end up leaving
you know her and they were going through
their thing so I stand by that because
we really were very happy for a very
long time very long time very long time
I still consider us a success story so
yeah you know it's so funny so after all
of it I I say that to him like you know
I'm not going to poo poo on the whole
thing like there were really great parts
and even if it was one-sided in certain
areas like it still was real for me and
it was beautiful for me and I think
that's wonderful cuz not everybody feels
that in life not everybody gets a chance
and I think that's beautiful to be able
to feel that and you know it exists you
know so well okay so do you ever have
plans to retire CU 13 years I feel like
I'm looking at like Blake Shelton on The
Voice like it's like it's like you know
what I'm saying like that's hard I was
looking I was like this is going to be
hard for you man this is like a life for
you I'm think about what Porsha said to
me when she was little right yeah but
you're not dead you can't
quit you know I don't see myself ever
quitting you know acting you know things
like that but and that's my first love
but of course there's times I think you
know there's this has to come to an end
at some point you know it's not
necessarily you know aligned with who I
am at times you know because it's it can
be very you know difficult and
challenging and provokes me my anxiety
yeah but um it's hard because it's
really woven into you know my life for
so many years it would be very painful
even to walk away from just the the crew
and you know production and all that
because I love those people so much yeah
I do understand that I think people
don't realize that when they're watching
at home like how invested you get with
people people all become your family
it's very hard you see them more than
your family exactly yeah so one day we
it'll come though that day will come all
right all right well we need another
break but you can see the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills Wednesdays
on Bravo and streaming the next day on
peacock
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home